Land Unter in Villeneuve-Saint-Georges, rund
16 Kilometer vom Zentrum der französischen
Hauptstadt Paris entfernt.
Starke Regenfälle haben die nahe gelegene
Seine
und ihre Nebenflüsse stark anschwellen lassen.
In der Stadt mit rund 30.000 Einwohner herrscht
der Ausnahmezustand.
Viele Keller und Erdgeschosse sind mit Wasser
vollgelaufen,
viele Einwohner können nicht mehr in ihre Häuser gehen.
In einigen Vorgärten soll eineinhalb Meter
Wasser stehen.
Die Rettungskräfte sind mit Booten im Einsatz,
um die betroffenen Bürger in Sicherheit zu bringen.
Auch Lastwagen der Armee sollen hier zum Einsatz
kommen.
Dieser Mann ist besorgt:
"Wenn das weiter noch weiter steigt, dann
bin ich am Ende.
Eigentlich bin ich schon seit zwei Tagen am
Limit. Es steigt weiter.
Nur noch einen Zentimeter und ich werde komplett
überflutet.
Es hört sich nicht viel an, aber dieser eine
Zentimeter könnte entscheidend sein."
Auch in Paris steigt der Pegel der Seine weiter.
Bis Samstag erwarten die Experten neue Höchststände.
Der Bootsverkehr wurde eingestellt, U-Bahn-Stationen
und mehrere Museen haben vorsorglich geschlossen.
Die Eisenbahngesellschaft SNCF schloss mehrere
Innenstadt-Stationen.
Hausboot-Besitzer mussten ihre Schiffe verlassen.
Dieser Mann glaubt, dass sich die Menschen
in Paris an solche Zustände gewöhnen müssen.
"Ich denke, das schlechte Wetter wird nicht
heute oder morgen aufhören.
Es ist für eine längere Zeit.
Wir hören sehr viel über die globale Erwärmung
und Klimakatastrophen.
Es wird lange dauern, sich darum zu kümmern.
Das wird nicht leicht."
Eine Entspannung ist erst einmal nicht in
Sicht.
Der nationale Wetterdienst hat für 19 Departements
die Warnstufe orange ausgerufen.
Das ist die zweithöchste Warnstufe.
Die Bevölkerung wurde aufgerufen, unnötige
Reisen zu vermeiden und vorsichtig zu sein.